bueno
job aire apunta a reversar decisiones
clave tomadas por donald trump en
particular aplicando en política
internacional un enfoque mucho más
multilateral persona de las primeras
medidas que ha prometido es el retorno
de eeuu al acuerdo de parís sobre el
cambio climático el retiro de ese pacto
que decidió trump se hizo efectivo el 4
de noviembre hoy la administración
trombos dejó oficialmente el acuerdo de
parís y en exactamente 77 días una
administración baiden se volverá a unir
a él desde europa saluda en la
perspectiva de volver a fortalecer los
lazos transatlánticos debilitados por el
aislacionismo deschamps conozco a joe
biden como un gran partidario de nuestra
alianza y espero con interés trabajar
estrechamente con él una otan fuerte es
buena tanto para américa del norte como
para europa en otro ámbito desde la
organización mundial de la salud de la
que su hombre tiró a su país en medio de
la pandemia de coronavirus también ven
con optimismo y cambio de rumbo en
washington y felicitaciones al
presidente electo joe biden y a la
vicepresidenta electa kamala harris mis
colegas de la organización mundial de la
salud y yo esperamos trabajar con
ustedes
crisis como la pandemia de kobe 19
muestran la importancia de la
solidaridad mundial en la protección de
vidas y medios de vida juntos y no se
descarta que joe fighting constaba en la
vicepresidencia cuando se dio la firma
del acuerdo nuclear con irán en 2015
reintegre a eeuu a este pacto que las
potencias europeas han intentado
mantener desde que se anunciara su
retiro en mayo de 2018 arbitrage de
nuestra administración indicó que el
objetivo era la presión máxima era
disuadir la agresión regional y negociar
un mejor acuerdo nuclear
y está por verse qué pasará con el
bloqueo a cuba que barack obama había
empezado a aliviar y donald trump
reforzó